salut à tous aujourd'hui on est le
dimanche 15 janvier 2017
c'est une vidéo un petit peu spécial que
je veux faire aujourd'hui parce que ça
fait un mois exactement jour pour jour
que j'ai lancé le blog je vous faire une
vidéo sans montage sans code sans rien
donc je vais tout vous dire dans un
temps minimum et je vais essayer
d'éviter de bafouiller
cette fois ci j'ai pas l'excusé du
montage donc fatalement je risque de
bafouiller
donc là on est voyez dans mon petit
studio de montage dans lequel je fais
mes vidéos un décor que si vous regardez
les vidéos vous devez connaître un petit
peu donc aujourd'hui dans cette vidéo je
voudrais surtout qu'on parle pas de moi
mais qu'on parle de vous mc on parle de
toi surtout d'ailleurs c'est toi qui
m'intéresse j'aimerais déjà dans un
premier temps de remercier parce que
comme je te le disais ça fait déjà un
mois que je fais ce blog au quotidien
trente et une vidéo ça demande quand
même pas mal de temps et je tiens à te
remercier pour ta présence
tu vas découvrir pas longtemps tu es là
depuis probablement un mois encore
probablement moins mais tu es là merci
et d'ailleurs j'ai fait une petite liste
de personnes que je souhaiterais
remercier dérange pas on va se mettre
plus à l'aise dans le fauteuil derrière
probablement au mieux si j'ai bien voilà
à s'écoule un petit fauteuil rouge c'est
la classe alors j'ai quelques noms que
j'ai noté et je tiens vous passer un
petit bonjour et vous remercier d'être
là alors entre autres il ya elena
jennie-anne arnaud jade nathalie david
tatiana philippe jean et puis tous les
autres
vous êtes très nombreux alors la chaîne
n'a pas encore énormément d'abonnés mais
en tout cas vous êtes des abonnés de
qualité et c'est à ce titre là que je
tiens à te remercie tout
particulièrement alors une chaîne qui a
je vous dis un blog depuis un mois un
mois passé si tu te rends compte mais ça
fait quand même énormément tav beaucoup
de nuits blanches
et puis peu d'heures de sommeil j'ai
regardé il a sûrement saumon iwatch
south shore s'appelle même pas le watch
j'ai regardé je dois dormir en ce moment
5h05 heure et demie en moyenne voilà
c'est quand même relativement sympa bon
alors c'est une moyenne il ya des nuits
à 2 heures il ya des nuits à cette heure
donc
donc s'il ya des fois je dors néfastes
or pâle une sale gueule et des poches
sous les yeux voilà donc merci beaucoup
on est environ à donc à trente et une
vidéo 18000 vue pour le moment donc
c'est un début j'espère qu'il y aura
beaucoup plus à ça dépend de toi de toi
et puis de vous tous donc merci alors on
a parlé prennent de pas mal de choses
hein pendant un mois on a parlé de coupe
on a fait j'ai fait beaucoup de blogs
on a parlé des ennemis vous avez vu dès
que des potes à moi d très bon ami à moi
on a parlé aussi de la vie d'hommes
célibataires de la vie de l'homme tout
court de cuisine c'est un début un jeu
lens
je lance des rubriques cuisine ou une
fois par semaine je vais vous donner le
bon plan pour sortir de la galère tous
les mecs parce que transporte des fois
on n'est pas très bon cuisine noria des
cordons bleus un besoin d'un paquet qui
sont vraiment naze et bon l'idée c'est
quelques petites astuces tout simple
pour sortir en faisant des plats qui
sont vraiment sympas qui ont de la
gueule et qui sont très très bon en un
rien de temps avec pas grand-chose
remplace donc voilà on ne parla par le
toit donc c'est qu'un début ce sont des
choses qui vont continuer à se mettre en
place j'ai plein de projets
deux côtés dont je te ferai pas très
très prochainement
moi ce qui m'intéresse raciste tu
puisses tu me parler de toi déjà
j'aimerais savoir qui tu es là j'ai cité
quelques personnes que j'ai plus un
petit peu je dirais identifié qui sont
là régulièrement qui commentent et que
j'ai un plaisir à lire maintenant il ya
tous les autres toiles à derrière que je
ne connais pas encore 10 mois déjà qui
tue et ce serait super sympa de faire un
petit peu plus la connaissance qui tu es
ou est-ce que tu habites quel âge tu as
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie tu es
en couple célibataire tu as des gosses
pas de gosses qu'est-ce que tu ailles
voilà et puis dix mois en plus ce que tu
aimerais voir est ce que tu attends moi
probablement pas grand chose mais si tu
pouvais interagir et ceux qui pouvaient
donner une ligne une direction aux
vidéos
qu'est ce que tu aimerais de quoi est ce
que tu aimerais que je parle quels sont
les sujets qui t'intéresse
qu'est ce que tu ne veux absolument pas
voir et puis dix mois en quoi en quoi
s'acheter end intéresse puisque tu es là
pourquoi tu les regardes et voilà donc
ça c'est super cool
et puis c'est très important d'avoir ces
retours ça me permet vraiment mieux de
connaître et de savoir
si ce que je fais tu te plais puisse
éventuellement je peux toujours
l'améliorer pour toujours plus de plaire
parce que mon but après tout c'est de te
plaire bon donc voila un petit peu pour
les différents sujets je me suis fait
des antisèches j'écris très mal donc ne
le montre pas je voulais pas ça oui je
voulais parler des concours
on a fait deux concours là le premier
concours c'était pour gagner
la tondeuse qui est parti donc merci
encore vraiment pas retenir que je ne
citerai plus enfin cette fois ci sauf si
une clinique d'autres cadeaux merci vous
avez été très nombreux à participer mais
il reste encore un concours en lice que
je ne fera gagner quand on aura atteint
les 500 abonnés c'est toujours ce fameux
parfum voilà je te mets le lien là dans
la vidéo attentats qui s'y voit là je te
mets le lien tu peux cliquer et comme ça
tu peux toujours accéder 1
il ya encore un peu de temps dès qu'on
est à 500 abonnés je fais gagner pour
l'instant n'est pas encore donc va
cliquer va regarder et participent
merci d'avoir été nombreux merci d'avoir
participé qu'est ce que je voulais
encore vous dire ben je crois que j'ai
fait un petit peu le tour de la question
face au wat avait passé trois heures
parce que ça va pas forcément de
passionnés voilà donc encore un grand
merci je vais profiter de ce dimanche en
faisant une vidéo un peu plus courte et
surtout beaucoup moins monté pour passer
un peu plus de temps avec les miens avec
ma compagne justine que je remercie
aussi parce que l'acceptent beaucoup de
choses de moi et nuit les nuits où elle
dort sans moi les nuits blanches la tête
fatigués des fois la mauvaise humeur
quand tu as mal dormi et pas toujours
évident à mon fils eliott aussi que je
jambes est un petit peu voilà merci à
toi merci d'être présent et puis je te
le dirai jamais assez si ce contenu te
plaît invite tes amis ça me ferait
plaisir de voir grossir le compteur
merci de partager merci d'être là
n'oublie pas il ya le compte facebook
instagram snapshot twitter google+ tous
les comptes sont présents sur ma chaîne
sur l'homme pas les petits liens tu peux
y aller tu peux aller voir
merci à toi je te kiffe tu es le
meilleur tu es la meilleure continue
comme ça change rien et à très bientôt
pour tout tu commentes un tu me mets
tous un mois je veux toutes les réponses
je veux vraiment con une discussion au
commentaire hein pas juste le fait de
regarder la vidéo jeudi entre guillemets
passivement mais vraiment quelque chose
d' actifs sur celle là on discute on
fait plus ample connaissance
et puis on voit là on ce plaisir bisous
à plus tard
tiao bon dimanche enfin bon le dis parce
que la vidéo sera diffusée lundi
allez j'arrête ciao